hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from round one of the
Croatia Grantchester being played in
Zagreb it's Wesley so vs. ding leerin
and as I said in the previous video we
didn't have any photos back then but I
do have some now so let's just check
them out for a moment here we have a
photo from the previous game cross and
vs. Giri they receive as part of making
the first move for onigiri now probably
Giri hopes it should have played a
different move but you know that's
that's all in the past also from this
game being versus the West and so we
have a nice close-up of Wesley there you
have it
rocking a you know a very nice ring or
so it would seem
and also here's a very nice close-up of
dink so let's just enjoy that for a
moment and now let's check out our game
and also I will be visiting the grand
chests were being played in Zagreb as
it's really close to me some half an
hour drive by car and maybe who knows
maybe I will get a chance to talk to
some of the players I will try to go
there a bit earlier so maybe some of
them will arrive early to the playing
venue so if you're interested share your
questions if you're interested in a
question towards any of them just write
it in the comments section below use
hashtag questions so I can filter them
out easily when I do the searching and I
will you know if if possible I will ask
them your questions and then present
them in in some of the other videos
maybe if it will be possible I have no
idea but you know it is possible so
returning to the game Wesley with the
white pieces opens with c4 so we have
the English opening now adding replies
with E 5 and g3 we have Knight to f6
sorry about that
Bishop to g2 Wesley can get over the
LightSquared bishop and the bishop to c5
now we have nice to see three and now c6
preparing d5 and Wesley does the same we
have III so the bishop is now not so
powerful and also white prepares d4 with
castles by dink and not nigh dg2 e2
preparing to castle and also at some
point preparing d4 with d5 by Wesley
CCAP force on d5 Knight chapters on d5
and now d 4s point
we've each capture some before and now
first night captures on d5
we have seek after Sun d5 and up until
this point they were following the game
Tingler and all already played he played
this position against Magnus Carlsen in
the ulti box Norway championship but the
Blitz action last year in 2018 where
cross and play tonight capture Sun
before but here Wesley goes for ich
after Sun before so it's hard to say if
ding is prepared for for this
continuation but for back to b6 this is
not a new move and there are I think
four or five games in the database where
castles was played but here Wesley
continues Knight to c3 and this is now a
new move in the position so obviously
you can deliver rook rook e8 check white
will just block that so it's not really
all that powerful here ding just
continues Knight to c6 with Bishop to e3
by Wesley as the pawn on d4 was under
attack and the Bishop to e6 ding
continuous development with castles by
Wesley and now Queen to d7 biding
developing the Queen connecting rooks
also this Queen Bishop battery is now
ready to go Bishop to h3 you wanna
exchange the light square bishop as soon
as possible and then try to create some
sort of an attack maybe with H 5 H 4 if
possible with nice day for going for
this dark square Bishop here and ding
says okay I don't mind I don't really
like Knight Bishop here anyway he just
goes rook to b8 he develops his rook we
have captures eight captures here and
now Queen to b3 so going after the b6
pawn and here ding just defends it rook
to a6
so a bit of a trade-off ding now has a
doubled beep on but he also has the same
e open a file for his rook will he be
able to use it in a in a useful way
it's hard to say as for now the rook is
stuck guarding the b6 pawn with rook F
the see one now by Wesley and Bishop to
h3 finally you want to trade off the
delight for bishops but Wesley declines
the trade he goes Bishop to f3 and here
ding just repeats Bishop g4 he still
wants to get rid of his light square
Bishop back to G to rush up to h3 better
back to f3 Bishop to g4 and if Wesley
repeats one more time we will have a
draw by three
for repetition so Wesley of course
declines the draw I mean okay ding is a
bit higher rated and then Wesley is the
third highest rated player in the world
but still you don't want a draw with the
white pieces that's not the way chess is
played and the ding continues now the
attack the bishop is now on a well on an
awkward square so age 5 he wants to play
h4 capture here open up the H file or or
maybe even just push it all the way to
h3 depending on what white place west of
course doesn't want to allow this with
h4 and now Bishop to e2 making room for
the Queen either to come to g4 or an h3
in some weird scenarios but basically
you won't play Queen g3 and then there
should be back here to finally get rid
of White's light square bishop so King
to h2 preventing the Queen from going to
h3 and now Queen to f5 again Bishop to
f3 is the idea from dink with boishakh
to g2 and now first Knight to a5 kicking
the Queen away from b3 Queen to c3 and
now although you could go Knight to c6
seems like a very active square you
attack the dark square bishop but after
a brush up to f4 it's not you haven't
really achieved anything and after b3 is
played then I could just have to go back
so ding immediately goes back to C 6
blocks the Queen well infiltration of
the of the C file and now we have B 3 so
we have b5 preparing to get this rook
over to b6 you want to push b4 with
Queen to d2 and now Bishop to f3 finally
the bishop is under attack you want to
move it and dink wanted to move it
either way so again offers afraid of
light squared Bishop and Wesley again
declines Bishop to f1 and here look to
b6 it's a really weird move and you
really don't know what the rook is doing
and b6 you probably want to play before
and you can't do it well while the
rookies an a6
so that's obviously the idea but still
the rook will be very weird on b6 and
also it allows Wesley a wonderful
maneuver which Wesley plays and it's
well feel free to pause the video and
try to find it as it's really a nice
free maneuver not not for very long but
you have you have you have to see that
the rooks are now
nicely connected on dark squares so
Bishop 2f for grabbing more space while
also threatening Bishop to c7 to win one
of the rooks here being played rook to
c8 but now it's it really doesn't work
and it's really hard to see why it
doesn't work but that's one of the
things you also have to see when you
play the Bishop to f4 but now really
feel free to pause the video and try to
find there I say it a winning move for
white in this position I'll give you a
couple of seconds I don't really have
all that many problems with with my
voice well for the past day or two so I
don't have any water ready but for those
of you were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
trapper of bishops and for those if you
just want to enjoy the show
believe it or not rook to c3 it's it's
really an awesome move because the
bishop on f3 is unguarded and where are
you gonna go with the bishop of course
if you move the bishop to e4 then Bishop
to h3 nicely connects and you win
material here Queen will have to move
and you're gonna win the rook while the
bishop is still on f3 if you just play
Bishop to h3 the bishop would be able to
just block Bishop to g4 so Bishop to e4
is not possible dingos Bishop to g4 but
now comes the other part of the problem
f3 and the bishop is trapped so what do
you do here being finds a way to at
least get some compensation for the
piece he plays b4 forces the rook to
move away we have looked to d3 and now
you can see that the rook can come to C
2 if the knight moves also the Queen and
King are on the same second rank
so if rooks e2 and the Queen also guards
the C 2 square Dean finds a way to grab
Wesley's queen with Bishop captures an
f3 rook captures and now Knight to e5
offering a knight here but well the
reply will be rook to c2 and Wesley will
lose the Queen but here
Wesley plays the absolute best move so
once again feel free to pause the video
and try to find the best idea for white
here you don't always have to you know
save the queen for those who are able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent grabber of knights and for
those who just want to enjoy show D
captures e5
is the strongest because you already
grabbed one piece now you grabbed
another and if black really wants to win
your queen then you will also get a rook
so two pieces and the rook for a queen
that's you know that goes without saying
rook the sea - the only move for ding
there is no other way and now look to F
to dink wins the Queen rook captures
unbe - and now rook the c6 with some
ideas of infiltrating on the second rank
but it's really not a problem for white
Wesley goes to Bishop h3 we have Queen
to g6 and now just rook a to d1 and here
you don't really gain anything by
trading here white will just ignore you
and go for the d5 pawn let's say you
play d4 now you can just capture and
after Queen captures route blocks and
now you will lose this pawn everything
is nicely guarded Bishop guards rook
rugaard spawn form guards who are at
this point so there is really nothing
black can do here if he trades early so
ding still tries to keep himself in the
game we have rook to a 6 and now Bishop
to g2 going after the d5 pawn with d4
and now Bishop captures on b7 first the
rock is under attack we have looked to
a5 and now just rook captures on d4 so
Wesley says you can have the 80 point
it's really not a problem
Dean grabs it and now just look 1 2 B 2
defending Queen to b6 offering this rook
for this rook and Wesley says sure thing
we have route capture screen captures
and now just look back to d2 Queen to c3
hoping to win this pawn then maybe but
just maybe black would have some
compensation with the past C pawn but
most likely not with Bishop the d5
guarding the pawn of course Wesley's not
gonna give it up
and now King to f8 you don't have any
moves here with the black queen
everything is so nicely guarded there is
really nothing for the Queen to even try
so you have to bring your last piece
into the game of course which is the
King we have King to f8 and now Bishop
to c4 King to e7
but now Bishop to g5 check and now you
can't move anywhere with the King
because rook to b8 will be checkmate so
you have to block with f6 we have f6e
captures on f6g captures and now look
the e2 with
check came 37 and here Wesley just
played Bishop to d2 and it was in this
position that the England resigned the
game as there is nothing more for him to
do here he has to move the Queen let's
say Queen D for white we'll just win the
B for pawn and here this position would
be winning for white most likely even if
white didn't have a look here you can
just place your dark square Bishop here
on f4 to control the queening square and
you can get your light square Bishop
let's say 2 G 2 2 2 nicely support the
the pushing of the pawn but with which
the rook even in the game it is no
question how easily white would win this
of course the ink doesn't want to play
this out so after Bishop to b2 ding
resigned and an excellent victory for
Wesley so he spotted that Bishop to f4
moved to try and trap the rooks and
after they moved the rook then he saw
that the Bishop was trapped and it was
all over so really really an impressive
game and not sure how much were it was
preparation but I don't think a lot as
we we had a annex and entirely new game
fairly new as of move 10 so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank at Irish Car Pack for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous video so
your think all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content I forgot to mention
all of the photos here are courtesy of
Leonard Otis official photographer of
the green chest or if you if you enjoy
the photos you're welcome to check out
more of them I will put a link to his
Instagram and Twitter page in the
description below so do check it out
if you enjoy such nice photos thank
y'all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day